ce temps que je peux tuer n'importe qui
et pourquoi elle vous a épargné vous
j'en sais rien du tout ni témoin vous
ont identifié vous et vous seul votre
maison est en passe d'être saisi vous
devez des arriérés sur toutes vos cartes
de crédit et aujourd'hui vous perdez
votre boulot ça ressemble à quoi ce
tableau vous un manque de chance
quand un homme a tout perdu je m'appelle
rich
on est dans la même galère c'est quoi
votre intérêt à vouloir vous occupez de
mise affirme wac est encore un minimum
d'espoir en toi mon pote
d'où vous connaissez mon prénom
il devient vulnérable à la tentation
qu'est ce que tu veux vraiment au fond
de toi je parais qu'elle te fais des
trucs que tu as fan de frais jamais allé
prévert il attend quelque chose que moi
on dirait que j'avais dit qu'il se
comportait comme s'il était mon ami
quand un homme est vulnérable
tu me dire que le bâtard quitte à
lourdes est ici et qu'est ce qu'on
attend pour aller lui exposer la tête il
devient la proie idéale du mal le monde
est sans pitié je fais le maximum dans
cette histoire si jamais ce film le mal
est fait quand j'arrive
à l'ont massacré ce fils de [__] c'est
moi qui gère la faire moi je me contente
de tuer des épaves qui sont déjà mortes
attention
s'il vous plaît arrêtez
on joue plus maintenant tu n'as rien vu
du tout encore cherche pas comment je
suis du genre original
qu'il y ait un souci ce que à
l'intention de tuer ma famille vous
comprenez ça
on est tous les deux dans cette galère
jazz to me qui mêle leaf
mais c'est la pure vérité
rencontre avec le mal mais le doute est
mauvais